hey guys it's Greg in Arianna Arianna
one of the most pretty girls that's ever
come on the channel is here today and
just smile pretty
most just smile great you're reminding
me of my last job
no Ariana you're gorgeous my girls hopes
are gonna show so maybe I'll just let it
happen sex appeal bra straps are so sexy
because it's one step closer to seen the
whole broad guys are dumb like that best
Coachella vines from the best vines
channel alright we got two minutes and
30 seconds of Coachella lines and now on
to Rick story on Coachella Rick a gang
of miniature thieves stole my wallet
what please send help
stop talking about Coachella
golly she's small
like she's alright
we already said that what do we want we
are confused huh
Wow yes and a half minutes I gotta say
that's I mean while not always hilarious
that is a pretty accurate description of
what I see people tend to be like Oh
Charles around yeah
what Coachella is coming up yeah I'll
let me talk about is how I'm gonna go to
Coachella like it's the coolest thing
that's about what people are gonna wear
to go tell them right yeah very much so
nobody when I go look on Instagram
recently it's like everyone who goes to
Coachella's like shirtless or half naked
and stuff yeah the idea of Coachella
I would like to experience however it
also sounds like it could be a really
icky experience like you got a campout
it's like three days sometimes two
weekends and it's like no probably have
these porta-potties I just I can't
hydrated sandy it's in the desert yeah
you're super rich yeah why wouldn't you
wanna go to Coachella mm-hmm he was
saying a house like people rent houses
there via shower
you know actually that could be cool
like will they feel like go to a hotel
or Airbnb a place that's near there and
you go there well that's a very common
thing that happens Wow did not know that
was common I would like to I thought you
have to camp out no we think rich people
necessarily camp out they are but rich
people aren't humble trust me we know
we're not humble people get houses and a
lot of people go and stay in desert
areas you mean there's no fella there's
no band at all that would make you go to
Coachella or no harvest
there's no I mean if I really loved an
artist why wouldn't I just go see them
in concert well-played Ariana it is not
my style I have too much anxiety and
like too much of a nervous person even
if you're on like a Molly or something I
don't want to ever be on drugs around a
bunch of strangers where I'm thirsty and
it's funny and you have to look like
very stylish yeah I mean that's the ones
that know anything about he's got to
look like stylish there and I'm like I
just want to be there for the fun that's
really trying to impress anyway look I
know some girls look really incredibly
sexy when they from
Coachella rejoice I'll start doing like
Coachella diets and work out right yeah
they're really getting in shape it's it
is like the most popular concert that's
crazy
or festival would mean it isn't knowing
though when I hear people preparing for
it all the time like it it's like all
these how hard they're looking to look
free-spirited that's it yeah they're
putting a lot of work into themselves
and now everyone's like getting me find
it for the flower crowns if I went I
don't want to wear a flower crown what
would you wear I can't even I would this
the idea of it in my head I can only
imagine what it could all like 30 pounds
thinner than I am I feel like you have
to start off very thin to pull off any
of the like little high waisted fringy
things for girls do guys have to be cut
you know what none of these things are
good message
I'd like to retract what I said be
yourself love your body but make sure
you look good I'm saying for myself yeah
you don't need to lose three more pounds
I would gladly see you in whatever a
clothing you're talking about
I mean H&M even made shirts at the
Coachella like I'd love to see the
person who wears the hmm brand Coachella
clothes aqua Chawla I mean I feel like
if you have big breasts is I mean that
makes up for a lot of it you feel like
engineer about chunky does it you can't
wear anything like billowy or free
spirit II okay I get what you're saying
balloon do people ever think your
breasts are fake yeah really
it was like how much you tits cause it
was a little bit to Argentina oh no I
don't know it's raised he had like a
cartoon photo as most of my fans I go to
Coachella I'm gonna get a tent that is
like huge if I'm not gonna rent out a
place I would get a tent that's huge
some type of fan because I hate can't do
you camp I have yeah I'm actually good
at it
I'm good at camp yeah no I know cemani
in the
and [ __ ] brown paper bags they made us
[ __ ] in bags and keep them with us what
don't make me imagine that it's true and
I slept in the snow for three days
was it cool yeah it's [ __ ] cold
sleeping in the snow okay a winter
survival are you still thinking about me
[ __ ] in a brown paper bag yeah well
it's cold
freezes reminds me of like it's not a
weapon please I would go if I had a lot
of drugs I know you don't want to do
drugs but I would want like ecstasy
Molly no I mean when I'm at Coachella
oh you're letting the audience down no I
wouldn't drink no that'd be you wouldn't
drink it maybe like hot I would I have
no idea you'd stay inside the hotel
probably honestly I know myself I'm not
good it's Coachella playing on the team
anyway dudes and dudettes and people who
are a lovely if you're new to this
channel you can subscribe today become a
reject yeah Arianna
badassery has a Facebook fan page link
in the description yes link in
description box she has a fashion blog
blog Arianna badassery com yes if you
like if you go to the Instagram the
links in the bio as we oh yeah better
her Instagram where there are supposedly
good photos of her never seen Lyons I'm
pretty sure I've looked through your
Instagram before a bikini shot okay yeah
it's confirmed I went to winter survival
that's it that looks really comfy now
Oh more bikini shots there boyfriend
that's all right no it's my friend
oh he's handsome he's got strong nose
it's not like big strong